MALLABY: OK, I think we can get started.
For those of you who don't know me, I'm Sebastian
Mallaby.
And I work here at the Council.
Welcome to today's meeting on the World Economic
Update.
This will be on the record.
And it's presented by the Maurice Greenberg
Center for Geoeconomic Studies.
We're going to get going with a panel of three
speakers.
On the far-my far left, your far right, as
he ruefully noted earlier, is James Grant,
founder and editor of Grant's Interest Rate
Observer.
Emma Dinsmore in the middle, cofounder and
chief executive of R-Squared Macro, which
is the hedge fund in Alabama, or a hedge fund?
DINSMORE: The?
MALLABY: It could be the.
DINSMORE: The.
MALLABY: The hedge fund in Alabama, OK.
(Laughter.)
And next to me, Lewis Alexander, managing
director and chief-sorry-a managing director
and chief U.S. economist for Nomura Securities
International.
So I think it's hard to not start with Brexit,
which was roiling the markets, especially
yesterday.
And maybe, Jim, I'll start with you.
There have been a whole queue of sort of blue
chip economists forecasting how much growth
Britain would forego if indeed the country
voted to leave the European Union.
The latest person to intervene is George Soros,
who predicts that you'd have a currency fall
bigger than in 1992 when he made all that
money by shorting sterling.
How do you see the-I mean, clearly there's
a negative effect from leaving Europe.
How big do you think it would be?
Would it be in the currency?
What do you think?
GRANT: Good morning, Sebastian.
Good morning ladies and gentlemen.
I would say, in the first place, that of all
the prognosticators on the future of this
British referendum, I dare say that George
Soros speaks with unique authority, certainly
with respect to the pound, and even more with
respect to the downside of the pound sterling.
But, Sebastian, with respect to the myriad
forecasts having to do with the imminent loss
of this and that in Britain, in the event
that leave should win, I would say that-I
would ask of those people who have made these
predictions, including the British Treasury,
the governor of the Bank of England, and on
and on, how many of them were on the right
side of the events of 2007 and '(0)8?
(Laughter.)
I would say the future is a closed book.
And if all the economists think one thing,
one is at least advised to imagine the alternative
outcome.
It seems to me that fundamentally the question
is not one of finance or of the future of
growth in Britain, but rather of a philosophical
nature.
When Margaret Thatcher was dealing with the
events of the late '70s and early '80s, she
was accosted by the members of her party about
the incomes policies that she had reviled.
And they said: Margaret, you cannot do without
them.
If the government does not lead industrialists
and unions in the direction-and you indicate
a proper direction for growth, we will be
in a very bad way.
And she said, in effect, my platform is freedom.
My platform is supply and demand and the individuals
making choices in markets.
So between the economists predicting disaster
on the occasion of a leave vote on the one
hand, and as the alternative of perhaps a
greater increment of freedom, a greater increment
of opportunity-entrepreneurial opportunity,
I would say, it's at least appealing to give
some thought to that latter.
MALLABY: So Margaret Thatcher was also, of
course, a supporter of EU membership, although
under terms which were tough that she negotiated.
Maybe, Emma, so, you know, I guess Soros makes
three comparisons with 1992.
He says that when sterling came out of the
exchange rate system then, at least when it
fell it boosted exports.
In this case, if it falls the export boost
will be muted, to say the least, by the fact
that you're leaving a trade agreement, or
you may be leaving that trade agreement at
the same time.
There's a bigger current account deficit now
in Britain so more of a reliance on foreign
capital.
And monetary policy is more constrained because
interest rates are already so low.
As somebody who trades macro how do you-do
you think that's right?
Do you think that the risks of a downside
shoot in sterling that could really be a Lehman
moment for Europe are there?
DINSMORE: I think it's really important to
put it in context of what's going on.
In terms of the depreciation of the pound,
I think certainly a Brexit is a huge headwind
to the pound.
Soros is estimating maybe 15 to 20 percent
decline in the pound.
I think maybe 10 to 15 seems reasonable.
You've seen that across the board with economists.
Mark Carney at the BOE has said that the pound
would be very vulnerable in that sort of scenario.
In terms of the trade implications, I think
they're somewhat muted by the fact that the
euro is likely to get hit as well, and any
kind of cross border trade there, there might
be a little bit of a wash, although I assume
that the pound will get hit greater than the
euro.
And that creates tremendous uncertainty.
I think beyond that, if Brexit passes, we're
looking at three years of negotiation for
the U.K. to come up with its own trade agreements,
which the U.K. has not unilaterally negotiated
a trade agreement since the 1970s when it
joined the EU.
It doesn't even have those infrastructures
in place to do that.
So I think that that-the uncertainty on that
outlook alone, what that means truly for the
U.K. economy, what the dynamics of the new
trade agreements will be, how it will affect
exports in an environment where global trade
is already dampened, really certainly present
headwinds for the pound.
I expect credit spreads would likely blow
out.
But I don't know if you would see a Lehman
size event.
I think more likely you'd see something more
akin to what we saw with the European financial
crisis.
And really, the response is going to depend
on how credible central banks handle it.
I think that they're well-prepared.
I think that there's been a lot of cooperation
among central banks.
I believe that the Fed's decision to delay
rate normalization clearly influenced by Brexit.
There's clearly a lot of preparation on that
front.
So the extent there's some credibility in
there and a swift policy response, you might
need some of that.
But definitely short term volatility.
MALLABY: And, Lewis, the idea of a central
bank policy response does run up against the
issue of two things.
First of all, the zero lower bound is not
that far off, so how much can you really cut?
And particularly how much can you cut without
hurting U.K. banks?
And secondly, you know, in an environment
where you have an enormous current account
deficit, you need to attract capital, cutting
rates is obviously a problematic strategy.
So do you-I mean, the Lehman idea, I guess,
is that you have this shock.
People are not expecting it.
And that's true.
After yesterday, they're not expecting it
because of a few polls.
If it's unexpected and the policy response
I complicated, could this spiral out of control.
ALEXANDER: I have a hard time getting to that,
in part because while it-you know, we're talking
about very short timeframes.
I mean, in some sense the two weeks before
Friday was the period when markets were, in
some sense, getting used to the notion.
Second of all, I would argue the banking systems
is substantially better capitalized than it
was in 2007, 2008.
So I think the inherent vulnerabilities around
that are less.
I would stress the fact that nothing really
happens immediately with this vote.
It's just a recommendation.
As was noted, it's going to take a long time
to figure out what it actually means.
And so I have no doubt markets are going to
react, including foreign exchange markets,
but I think-look, I would never say never,
but I don't think the right first-case assumption
should be some sort of systemic issue.
Look, I would sort of agree with the first
set of comments, that it's, you know, hard
to know what this means in the long run.
But I think it means some obvious things in
the short run.
One is a lot of uncertainty.
And uncertainty is generally not good for
economic activity.
It's particularly not good for economic activity
in an environment where macro policy responses
are constrained.
So for just the issues of monetary policy,
doesn't have a lot of options; fiscal, doesn't
seem to be an option.
So just the near-term dynamics of a significant
increase in uncertainty without a policy response
is problematic.
I would also note that structural reform,
whatever its benefits in the long run, tends
to be negative in the short run.
It's often hard to, I think, generate big
changes in structure, even if they are ultimately
positive, and orchestrate it in a way that
generates a positive effect in the short run.
And so the kind of near-term dynamics around
whatever you think the benefits or costs are
going to be in the long run, it's hard for
me not to see it as being a challenge in the
short run.
I do think the biggest issue outside of the
U.K. is going to be the financial spillovers.
And that's the thing which I think is sort
of hard to predict.
But that'll be the biggest issue outside of
the U.K.
MALLABY: Jim, this issue of policy constraints-so,
if we think about not just the U.K. but more
about the euro zone, you've got not only monetary
policy which is already very active-hard to
see how it could be a lot more active.
But also, even if you could theoretically
imagine more activism, Germany is reluctant
to let the European Central Bank go any further.
So if there was-if there was a shock, and
the shock might be Brexit or it might be something
in the Spanish election this Sunday where
the Marxist left is expected to get about
a quarter of the vote-in the event of that
kind of shock, the central bank is a bit constrained,
fiscal policy is constrained by EU politics
as well.
You've been associated, I think it's fair,
with a view that policy is often too activist
and you should let things adjust.
Do you feel comfortable with that in this
case in Europe?
I mean, is the right thing to admit that we
don't have policy tools all the time?
And would Europe be better off if it took
the hit and?
GRANT: Well, I think Europe would be better
off if the, as they are called, the authorities
did less rather than more.
I have in mind particularly the hyper-innovationism
of the European Central Bank.
You know, my business, my publication is called
Grant's Interest Rate Observer.
So I speak with an interest, there are no
more interest rates to observe.
I'm a little bit sore about this.
(Laughter.)
But interest rates are prices.
They are arguably the most sensitive and important
prices in capitalism.
They define internal rates of investment.
They help us think about risk.
They discount future cash flows for the benefit
of investors and business people.
And I think the way to think about this word
we use, this kind of surgically clean phrase,
policy choices or policy tools-one way to
think about this is the-is the government
systematically administering prices which
arguably ought better to be discovered in
the marketplace.
So you ask, Sebastian, about policy response
to these prospective events.
And I think it would be blessing indeed if
some way or other, the European Central Bank
decided it would not impose its will on interest
rates in the euro zone.
As it is now, the European Central Bank has
gone beyond buying sovereign debt hand over
fist to buying corporate bonds, such that
we see securities issued by fallible, mortal
corporations priced to yield less than nothing,
meaning you pay them for the privilege of
giving them your cash.
Certainly very little is ever new under the
sun of finance.
This is new.
MALLABY: This is Unilever you're talking about?
GRANT: Well, there are 50-odd billion (dollars)
of security, short-dated to be sure, that
are being priced.
I mean, as in Japan, value is no longer a
consideration in fixed-well, I was about to
say fixed income.
That too is a misnomer.
(Laughter.)
MALLABY: Fixed donation.
Fixed donation securities have become the
new-
GRANT: Yeah.
So I think there's-I think there's a great
deformation-deforming of markets.
And the owner of that problem, I think, or
the cause of that problem is principally the
European Central Bank.
MALLABY: But just to press you, so the answer
to this deformation is a reformation where
the European Central Bank quits buying securities,
therefore interest rates zoom up-
GRANT: Well, therefore interest rates are-interest
rates are allowed to go where they might go,
the better to discount future cash flows and
to reflect risk.
As it is, with sovereigns of no particular
distinction yielding about nothing before
tax, and corporations are the same, how are
we to think about risk in any sensible way?
And what lies beyond is massive interventions.
How do we-how do we refinance these debts
when they come due and need to be either paid
or refinanced?
So I think what you're talking about, Sebastian,
is the putting off of some-not necessarily
an evil day, but it's certainly a day of clarification.
MALLABY: Well, maybe we should switch on that,
so we can segue to the U.S., where the Fed
last week indicated that it would be looser
for longer than expected some months ago.
GRANT: Expected some days before.
(Laughter.)
DINSMORE: Well, the call from Carney came
through.
MALLABY: Emma, one thing that Yellen cited
in her press conference was actually foreign
risk, which seems to mean Brexit risk.
If we get through this referendum on Thursday
and that risk is off the table, should Yellen
go back to the tighter forward path?
You've got-I mean, talk about where we are.
We're at full employment.
Is inflation heading back to trend in a way
that feels comfortable?
Or is there still a case for keeping rates
super low for a long time?
DINSMORE: So I think the challenge is you
can't look at the U.S. economy in a vacuum.
So obviously the Fed's mandate has to do with
full employment and inflation, but in the
context of today's global economy, with declining
GDP output across the globe and China exporting
disinflation everywhere, the Fed has to be
inherently concerned about what's going on
abroad.
The Brexit obviously provided an acute risk
for the Fed.
The implied volatility of that if Brexit passes
could be tremendously unsettling for the U.S.
economy.
So it certainly makes sense that Yellen would
have taken a pause.
In terms of going forward domestically, I
think the U.S. economy as a whole looks fairly
decent.
We've had a very long and somewhat lackluster-it's
not been a really exciting recovery, but we've
certainly had a recovery.
And I would say, if I'm looking at his from
the Fed's perspective, I think that the U.S.
economic recovery is a bit long in the tooth,
in terms of just a short-term cyclical recovery.
And so if I'm in the Fed's position I'm a
little bit concerned about a potential downturn
in the U.S. and sitting at such low rates.
MALLABY: But you could just trigger the downturn
if you tighten prematurely.
DINSMORE: Right.
Right.
So that's the conundrum that the Fed sits
in.
So I think that short term financial volatility
caused by external factors obviously creates
a situation where you do not want to be tightening
because you add to that uncertainty, you add
to the financial instability.
But I think the Fed is clearly looking for
opportunities to tighten.
I think that-I expect them to raise rates
maybe one or two more times by early next
year, just to give themselves some policy
room.
And I think if you look at the language that
Yellen used in her latest statement, much
less emphasis this time on inflation than
on employment.
So in the past, Yellen has been tremendously
concerned about the headwinds to U.S. inflation-so
low oil and the strong dollar.
But as the base effects of those roll off
the calendar, you're now starting to really
believe that inflation-disinflation in the
U.S. is probably transitory.
And so the outlook for inflation I think,
from the Fed's perspective, is likely stabilizing.
Obviously it has a way to go, but still stabilizing.
So that front is a little more comforting
for the Fed.
And I think that on the labor market side,
the labor market as a whole has been doing
fairly well.
Obviously the NFP print was a shock.
I think there's debate within the Fed about
whether or not that's statistically significant
or if it's noise.
Obviously-as the economy reaches full employment,
I think there's some debate about whether
or not we're there, there will be some decline
in job gains.
It's just natural sort of course of things.
So I think the Fed is willing to look past
that.
My base case scenario is that once the Brexit
risks pass, the Fed's going to look for opportunities
to raise rates.
If you see any decent type of employment numbers
coming out, nothing suggesting that last month's
NFP was a new trend, then you should probably
see the Fed beginning to raise rates again,
maybe in September.
MALLABY: So, Lewis, this idea that, you know,
the recovery is long in the tooth feels a
bit, well, this person is old so we should
sort of finish them off.
You know, so long as it's healthy-and healthy
could be defined as stable on a medium-term
view because inflation is 1.7 (percent), core
inflation, and it's not-it's still below target.
And as Emma pointed out, there's lots of disinflationary
force coming from outside, notably China.
Why not just let it continue?
What's the cost of just letting growth grow?
ALEXANDER: I think the thing the Fed is concerned
about is letting the economy get too far past
what you might think of as full employment
or whatnot.
So the unemployment rate is currently 4.7,
which is actually the low end of the range
of the forecast for the long-term unemployment
rate.
If you, in some sense, just let the economy
run and let that continue to fall, the Fed's
own interpretation of what drives inflation
is going to put themselves in a position where
they're going to have to raise the unemployment
rate at some point down the line to keep the
economy from, in some sense, overheating down
the road.
And that's problematic.
And I think that's the tradeoff they're facing
right now.
So I think we're-if you look at the latest
Fed forecast, it's sort of interesting.
They have growth at potential.
So they're-literally their forecast for growth
over the next three years are exactly at where
their long-run forecasts are.
They've essentially got the unemployment rate
going down a little bit from here, but not
very much.
And in some sense, they're predicting an economy
that is essentially moving along the full
employment path.
And you can think about the interest rates
that they've written down as this is their
judgement of what is the path of interest
rates that's consistent with that outcome.
Now, if the economy were to, in some sense,
accelerate, I think you'd see them raise rates
more.
If the economy does not continue to generate
pressures that have the unemployment rate
falling, then I think they'll sort of hold
pat.
But I think that's the sort of logic of where
they are.
I totally agree that there's no real urgency
here.
And in the wake of volatility and risk, they
are going to be pretty conservative in terms
of how they transition.
But I would totally agree that if you get
some better economic data they are on a trajectory
where they believe they need somewhat higher
rates ultimately to keep them on that path.
MALLABY: Jim, there's been a couple of times
I guess in the last couple of decades where
the Fed has confronted a situation where price
inflation seemed to be under control, and
yet there were big imbalances building up
in financial markets and probably, in my view,
not tightening at those points was a mistake.
So I'm thinking of 1999 where the tech bubble
was inflating and the Fed was very slow to
act because it thought price inflation ain't
there, so why should we?
And kind of the same in 2004, 2005 with real
estate.
Do you see anything like that now?
Is there a cost to sitting there with low
rates because imbalances may be building up
someplace in finance that could bite us later?
GRANT: Without a doubt.
Certainly they're-I mean, the Fed, since 2008,
has been implementing a policy that might
be likened to putting the cart of speculation
in front of the horse of enterprise.
Kind of the three-dollar phrase was portfolio
balance channel.
What the Fed intended was that a rise in the
value of various financial assets, real estate,
equities and the like would induce greater
spending by the owners of assets.
And this spending would, as it were, trickle
down-that phrase, I think, was not used-but
it would trickle down into other segments
of the community.
And we would be seeing the fruit of-well,
the outcome would be greater aggregate demand.
That was the idea.
And what we have achieved collectively is
much higher asset prices.
Commercial real estate, so-called cap rates,
are very near the old highs.
Interest rates you know about.
Bond prices you know about.
Equity is not quite sky-high, but certainly
treetop level.
And I think the Fed is in a bit of a bind
with respect to the divergence between activity
on the one hand and asset prices on the other.
And so the industrial economy, it seems to
me, is very near recession.
Other portions of the economy, not so much.
But if you are in the business of engineering
a rise in assets prices, and if the earning
basis of those assets, as to say the real
economy, is slipping away, what do you do?
And by keeping interest rates low, and by
encouraging further speculation in assets
with borrowed money you are building yourself
the next crisis, which will entail still a
greater dose of radical monetary intervention.
So yes, Sebastian, it seems to me that there
are terrific risks associated with these policies.
Not just last FOMC meeting, but the string
of interventions going back even before the
crisis of 2007 and '(0)8.
MALLABY: And we can maybe come back to that
when we go to questions, which I want to do
in a minute.
But I want to get to China before we open
it up.
So, Emma, the concern amongst outside observers
of China used to be you guys manage your currency
and you're exporting low prices, deflation,
through that route.
Now it is you guys have got massive overcapacity
in steel and so forth, and you are exporting
deflation through a new route.
From China's point of view, the first strategy
worked quite well, managing the currency for
a long time.
But the overcapacity is going to be more painful
to work out.
How do you think, both in the near-term and
in sort of-on a five-year view, how does China
work its way through this problem of enormous
amounts of industrial capacity, with lots
of debt associated with that, and no clear
markets for the steel they're producing?
DINSMORE: Right.
Yeah, so I think China has two choices.
One is to swallow the pill and make the reforms
that it needs to do to modernize its economy
and continue down that path.
And the other is to kick the can down the
road and to continue to refinance this and
continue to go back to old ways of infrastructure
investing and doing that.
And so I think the better outcome for China
is to move down this path of building a consumption-oriented
economy, and accepting the slower growth in
the short term that will come with that because
ultimately the only way to work out this excess
capacity is to grow a consumer base to use
it and to accept the lower growth in the short
term.
Obviously China-moving down that course is
very challenging for China.
I think that there are a lot of economic and
political risks to them doing that, to having
such a massive slowdown so quickly, and also
globally challenging.
So you're seeing them defray to kicking the
can down the road and continuing more of the
same.
But ultimately, I think China needs to start
reforming-pushing through more structural
reforms to create broader safety nets, social
safety nets, to encourage more saving-or,
I'm sorry-more consumption, and let that gradually
work through the economy.
Either way, China's going to export disinflation,
whether it was through their low currency
or through excess capacity.
It's going to be a fact of the global economy.
There's not much they can do about that.
And really, China's best outcome longer term
is to tap into this potential-this really
large potential consumer base.
Over the long run that's a much more sustainable
economy for them.
It's much more stable and much more attractive,
although short run a little painful.
ALEXANDER: Yeah, just to build on that a little
bit, I think there's a little bit of a kind
of glass half full, glass half empty.
China is slowing.
They are doing this transition.
It's sort of a question of how quickly.
I think we've seen over the last year that
they have gone through cycles where it felt
like growth was at risk, they provided some
stimulus, but at the same time not full, you
know, foot to the accelerator, in the way
they did in, say, 2008 and 2009.
They are clearly accepting a slower path to
growth.
And there's sort of a question of does the
transition path work?
Look, I think the domestic financial problem,
which is essentially the financial counterpart
to the sectors that have this excess capacity
is going to be a challenge to manage domestically.
I worry about it in a context where China
is opening up in certain ways financially,
which is making themselves more vulnerable
to market dynamics and finance.
And that's an inherently challenging thing.
I think they have the fiscal capacity to manage
it.
Essentially the financial system is fully
backed.
But it is-it is going to be a tricky thing.
And they've got a large asset quality problem
in their banking system, which is going to
take them many years to sort of work through.
But you know, I don't think it's obvious that
it isn't manageable.
I do think the overcapacity, what it implies
for trade going forward, is something that
we're going to hear more about and have to
worry about.
Just anybody who's looked at the history of
the steel industry is the history of the steel
industry globally is global excess capacity
leading to trade problems, right?
In the sort of '60s it was excess capacity
in Europe.
In the '70s and '80s it was excess capacity
in Japan.
And now-and both of those problems are dwarfed
by the situation in China.
And so that is going to be something that
we are all going to have to manage.
And in an environment where, frankly, I think
trade is going to be a bigger part of the
agenda going forward, it is going to be-you
know, it's something we're going to have to
be dealing with.
MALLABY: Right.
The politics of the West are not such that
absorbing a surge in cheap manufactures is
politically easy.
ALEXANDER: Yeah.
MALLABY: At this point, let's invite members
to join the conversation.
Remember, this is on the record.
So if you have a question wait for the microphone
and I will call on you.
One right here, yes.
Coming up.
Q: Yeah, thank you.
Juan Ocampo with-(comes on mic)-Can you hear
me?-Trajectory Asset Management.
Jim, I got a question for you about an interest
rate that cannot be observed, the so-called
natural rate that John Williams of the Fed
has written about for a long time, et cetera.
As you know, 30 years ago that rate, as they
calculate it, was 500 basis points, and now
it's-they tend to calculate it around zero.
And it's being used as something that interventionists,
as you would say, for very loose monetary
policy say, well, we have to keep it very
low because the natural rate is low.
The question for you is, do you think the
rate-the natural rate is so low because of
this ongoing intervention that's been going
on for so many years that the patient, essentially,
is showing a different symptom profile?
GRANT: Well, I do.
One shouldn't dogmatize about an interest
rate that exists only in the imagination of
the mandarins of monetary policy.
Actually, there is an extensive literature
on the natural rate that antedates Knut Wicksell,
who died in, I think, 1926.
The so-called Austrian school, now mostly
associated with Hayek and Ludwig von Mises,
talked about a natural rate at which the demand
for savings was equal to the supply force
savings, not bank credit force-fed into the
system through unique and heretofore unimaginable
central bank actions, but rather savings-deferred
consumption.
So I think that the notion of the-of this
invisible friend to the central banks called
the natural rate, this secret, invisible friend.
This is a kind of a contrivance.
I think it is an intellectual contrivance
that is used in argument to justify these
increasingly grotesque interventions.
And The Wall Street Journal reported on the
so-called natural rate.
And somebody was, you know, it's-you can't
see it, but you can infer its existence.
It's like the planet Pluto.
(Laughter.)
And I was thinking, no.
They have not discovered Pluto.
Rather, they have blundered onto Goofy.
(Laughter.)
ALEXANDER: Can I jump in here?
MALLABY: Sure.
ALEXANDER: Look, you can make this concept
very artificial and whatnot, but ultimately
it comes back to a very simple question, which
is: What is the relationship basically between
growth and interest rates?
This whole debate about the natural rate and
how you measure it is really just looking
at that.
Let's look at the last six months.
The last six months, the U.S. economy has
grown at about 1.1, 1.2 percent, with real
rates that are essentially zero.
I would argue that 1.1 is almost certainly
below anybody's estimate of what potential
is.
So the normal definition of the neutral or
natural rate that is commonly used in the
monetary policy debate is what is the level
of interest rates that gets the economy to
grow at potential?
It's a very simple observation to say that
whatever that rate is, it's in some sense
lower than where rates are now.
And when the Fed talks about that, that's
ultimately the issue they're talking about.
And I think when you-when you seriously try
and look at how the economy's behaved over
the last five years, it's hard not to draw
the conclusion that that relationship between
interest rates and growth is very different
from what we had before.
Now, I think what you're seeing in the discussion
around these issues within the Fed is struggling
to understand why that's the case and to try
to project forward, you know, how is that
going to happen going forward?
I would argue part of the problem with the
Fed over the last five years has been they
have been too optimistic about the recovery.
What you've seen consistently is them overestimating
growth and overestimating the path of rates
that the economy could accommodate.
Ultimately, that is about the path of this
very simple concept.
Going forward, what's going to matter?
I think the simple way to think about the
way the Fed is going to behave is they're
going to see how the economy responds.
If the economy picks up, that implies that
in some sense it can handle higher rates and
they can raise rates.
If it does not, they won't.
It's really that simple.
And in some sense, you can-you can make this
a bigger deal than it is.
But ultimately it's about the very simple
relationship between growth and the level
of rates.
DINSMORE: And I think on that point, in terms
of the Fed overestimating growth, I think
at the end of the day economic growth as a
whole boils down to confidence.
And if people are confident enough to invest,
if businesses are confident to invest, then
you start seeing that.
And I think that a lot of the Fed's-I would
agree the Fed has been overly optimistic.
But I imagine the counterfactual, in which
Janet Yellen says that she was tremendously
concerned about the outlook for the U.S. economy
and they didn't have this level of optimism
baked in, I think that would be disastrous
for confidence.
And I think that that also goes back to the
question about exceptional monetary policy,
and we talked about that in the ECB and the
euro.
I wonder in the absence of the ECBs intervention,
which I agree has been quite unprecedented
and exceptional, what really would the European
economy look like?
GRANT: Yeah.
Well, we talked about growth, which is an
income statement concept.
But we also ought to talk about leverage,
which is a balance sheet concept.
And if the Fed insists on pressing down rates,
or at least not lifting up rates, or doing
what it's doing, I guess, is the way to think
about its policy-if the Fed insists on persisting,
it seems to me we will see a great deal more
of what we are currently witnessing, namely
the incurring of debt to generate income that
is not there in the natural level, or the
observed level of interest rates, the nominal
rates.
What you don't see is what is going on with
the balance sheet side of things.
You can observe it at intervals, but I think
there is a preoccupation on growth to the
detriment of our awareness of the dangers
that heightened leverage to induce-or produce
income artificially, what that goes to finance,
and the kind of crises it introduces and the
kind of responses to those crises.
MALLABY: Another question?
Otherwise I've got a question.
Oh, I see one over here, OK.
Here, and then you.
Q: One of you observed that-
MALLABY: Could you just identify-
Q: I'm sorry.
Arthur Rubin with SMBC Nikko.
One of you observed that if Brexit were to
occur, that only would the pound head down,
but it would probably have a negative impact
against the euro.
There's a finite number of things that they
can go down against, which implies an even
stronger dollar.
The Fed-various members of the Fed have been
vociferous in saying that they're not going
to make their decisions based on what's happening
to the dollar in the rest of the world, yet
it's hard not to believe that at some level
there's kind of a veto over what the Fed does
by where the dollar is.
Do you think that a Brexit should occur, and
if it did have this knock-on effect on both
the euro and the pound, what does that mean
for the Fed's decision making policy and the
impact of the dollar rates?
For anybody.
DINSMORE: Well, I think if that happens you're
going to see easier monetary policy across
the board.
No country is supposed to-no central bank
is supposed to explicitly target their currency
as a policy lever, but obviously currencies
influence inflation.
And so it can't be ignored.
A stronger dollar is one of the biggest headwinds,
I think-or potential upside risks-or downside
risks of inflation in the U.S.
And you would most certainly see concerns-or,
renewed concerns about the inflation outlook
for the U.S. if the dollar breaks much higher
from here.
And really, I think, as you look at the Fed's
concerns about inflation-so their two concerns
about inflation had been low oil prices and
a strong dollar.
And the base effects of those on a calendar
year basis are scheduled to roll off, and
so you actually should see some inflationary
pressures.
But if you see the dollar spike again, that's
going to renew this disinflationary concern,
and certainly I think would prompt Fed members
to be hesitant to raise rates.
MALLABY: Teresa.
Q: Teresa Barger from Cartica Capital, visiting
from Washington, D.C.
I would just love it if you could talk about
two things.
One is productivity.
Pre-GFC, it was growing for 50 years at 2.5
percent, and since at 0.5 percent.
That's a U.S. number.
I don't-but similar in Europe and similar
in the emerging markets.
We've had a real stepdown in productivity.
And where do you see we might get out of that?
And the related question is with margins.
Corporate margins have come down.
I, of course, only know the emerging markets,
but it's also true in the U.S.
And are we seeing any green shoots of an uptick?
And where will that come from?
MALLABY: Go ahead then.
ALEXANDER: I'm happy to talk about productivity.
First of all, I would question a little bit
the way you characterize it.
When you said 2.5 percent before the global
financial crisis, it's-
Q: Over 50 years too.
ALEXANDER: Well, but what you, in fact, had
was relatively high productivity growth until
around the mid-'70s.
It then fell quite dramatically.
We had a little bit of a recovery starting
in the mid-'90s that lasted for a decade or
less.
And that's kind of where you get that average,
but in fact it's not literally constant.
In some ways what's happened is we've come
back to those lower levels we saw in the '70s
and, frankly, lower levels that we saw before
the 1920s.
This is-there's a lot of interesting work
that's going on on this subject at this time.
There's a book by Bob Gordon, who I-it's a
little too long.
It could have used an editor.
But it's actually a very good book.
I think there are good reasons to expect low
productivity growth as something where it's
here to stay.
It's not that there aren't positive things
going on, but I think they're less broad than
they used to be.
One of the simple ways to think about it is
as wonderful as IT is, and lord knows that
is the thing that we're living with, how many
people are actually-how many workers are made
better by IT, versus how many workers are
effectively substitutes to IT?
When you think about the technologies that
drove those previous waves of innovation-things
like electricity and the internal combustion
engine-one of the characteristics of those
things was they made everybody.
And I think we're living in a world where
that's much less true.
And so I think it's reason to be less optimistic.
As I look at the data, I think there's very
little evidence to expect an uptick.
And so my expectations are built on the judgment
that I'm not expecting productivity to accelerate.
That's not to say that it couldn't happen.
Frankly, economists are lousy at predicting
productivity.
So we should say that very clearly.
But I do think a low productivity world is
part of what we're living with.
When you look around the world, at emerging
markets and others, what you generally see
is slowing productivity everywhere.
It's a little bit of a different story.
The stories you would tell for the U.S., which
we think of as being kind of at the frontier,
is a little bit different than what you would
think of as an emerging economy that presumably
is not at the frontier and ought to be able
to, in some sense, generate stronger productivity
growth by moving towards the frontier.
I think you have to tell kind of different
stories.
But it is certainly true that the data would
suggest that this slowdown in productivity
is a near universal phenomenon.
And that is part of the problem of the world
we live in.
I think we are living in a world where growth
is slow.
And I think I would-I certainly feel like
monetary policy is, like, not the best too-and
I would argue it's the worst tool to address
that.
It may, of course, be the only one we can
use at the moment, which is kind of a different
problem.
But there's no question that there are other
things that we ought to be doing to try to
and address this.
And the frustration is it's just pick your
country, you tell a different story for why
that's not happening.
MALLABY: And maybe, Emma, we could pursue
this a bit with you.
Because I think, I mean, Teresa had two questions.
And the other one was about corporate margins.
And maybe they're actually linked, in the
sense that some of what's going on with new
technology is stuff gets produced which is
valuable to consumers, the apps on my iPhone
and so forth, for which the price-the explicit
price is zero.
So it doesn't show up in a productivity gain
from the company that makes it, nor does it
produce a profit.
It may produce a welfare gain, but we're not
measuring it.
And maybe that's the linking factor in these
two questions.
DINSMORE: Well, I think it does.
I think in the global economy, technology
has really thrown a wrench into how we calculate
productivity and how we think about it.
And I'm not sure to the extent that technology
accounts for what percentage of the decrease
in productivity growth that technology accounts
for, but it certainly has to account for some
of it just because we simply don't understand
the true monetary value of data.
And data flows are skyrocketing globally.
And companies don't necessarily know what
they can monetize off of data.
Governments don't necessarily know what value
they're getting from it.
And it's hard to really derive any kind of
productivity or economic value to data other
than to see that data flows are tremendously
higher.
And I think the question for economists over
the next few years is how do we quantify that,
and what does that mean for global productivity
and how we think about growth, and what's
kind of the next wave?
I think it opens a lot of potential doors,
particularly in the realm of structural reforms
and innovations for economies, because in
some ways data is the great equalizer.
You know, if I have a smartphone I can do
things that I could never do with ten other
devices.
So I think that's going to open a lot of doors
for technological advancements and machination
across a lot of emerging markets, which could
be a really hopeful prospect for the global
economy.
But in the short term, really, there has to
be a lot of cohesion about what to do.
And as we mentioned right now, the main policy
response has been monetary policy.
And there has been a real disappointing lack
of anything else on the front of structural
reforms or fiscal policy to really push that
through.
MALLABY: But let me just suggest one analogy,
and see if any of you want to pick up on it.
So maybe this is sort of a Japan 1980s type
of thing, where, you know, the Japanese were
both-you know, the kind of-the stereotype
about Japanese business was it goes for market
share, it's great at getting market share,
it doesn't have enormous margins, super competitive.
And in some sense, technological shifts has
driven a lot of businesses, it seems to me,
into a mind frame where they want to get a
lot of eyeballs, they know that technology
creates lots of network effects if you're
the first mover, you have to create these
platforms.
You monetize down the road, a long time down
the road.
And in the meantime, you're accepting thing
margins, and you're not-you know, you're not
making consumers pay for what you're doing,
and you're willing to create both the effects
that you're talking about, both low corporate
margins and low measured productivity.
Does that-
GRANT: Yeah, they're not only low margins,
but nonexistent margins in the case-famously
in the case of the many unicorns in Silicon
Valley.
Notice that zero percent interest rates allow
the suspension, as it were, of disbelief about
future earnings.
And with respect to the measurement of productivity,
one is reminded of the difficulties of measuring
many economic phenomena.
There was a wonderful book published about-I
guess more than 50 years ago, Oskar Morgenstern,
on the accuracy of economic observations.
And he absolutely rips into the newspapers
of the day with their credulous reporting
of these data from the Commerce Department
to the right of the decimal place.
Can you?
And here we are talking about whether the
rate the inflation that the Fed is targeting
is 1.7 or 1.8, bearing in mind, for example,
that YouTube is for free.
I mean, how exactly-what precision do we expect
of these measurements?
And are we quite right in being, as Janet
Yellen is wont to say, data dependent?
I think the thing to know about Ms. Yellen,
among other things, is that she gets to the
airport three hours early for a flight.
(Laughter.)
She is not an impulsive person.
And perhaps she is right to be data dependent.
But one must think a little bit about the
accuracy of the data on which one depends.
MALLABY: Lewis.
ALEXANDER: So let me-let me kind of say a
couple things.
First of all, corporate profits are at record
highs.
All right, so if you look at the corporate
profit share, it's come down a little bit
over the last year, but the basic story of
the last 20 years has been rising corporate
profit shares.
So, yes, there are issues in the tech sector,
but it is not a generic problem for the economy
overall-number one.
Number two, one of the things to just be aware
of-and, look, I spent three years working
for the Department of Commerce.
So I was the chief economist at the Department
of Commerce, and sat over all these things.
And trust me, I understand full well the difficulties
in doing this.
GDP is not reality.
It's just a concept and it's an estimate.
We put way too much emphasis on it.
However, there are certain things that all
these numbers are benchmarked to.
And for example, all of our basically aggregate
measures are benchmarked to tax returns.
So if the question is, are we mis-measuring
productivity because we're not capturing income,
you have to believe-and if that's going to
explain the slowdown in productivity growth,
you have to believe that tax evasion has gone
up.
Now, I'm prepared to accept that it's gone
up some, but the notion that it's gone up
dramatically is kind of hard for me to get
my head around.
Alternatively, we know that our concepts of
output in big parts of the economy are just
very, very weak.
So a big part of our economy is services.
To be perfectly frankly, it's a lot easier
to measure physical stuff, right?
When the economy was dominated by manufacturing,
it was a lot easier to measure because you
measure how much steel comes out of steel
plants, you can measure, you know, how man
locomotives come out of the factories.
When you start talking about the output of,
say, the health care sector of the financial
sector, our concepts are a lot harder.
And so in some aggregate sense there's a huge
amount of uncertainty and mis-measurement
around these numbers.
But that's not really the question.
The question is what we are seeing is a notable
slowdown in productivity.
And to, in some sense, believe that that is
because of mis-measurement, you have to believe
that all of those problems have gotten materially
worse.
And I would argue the serious people who have
gone out and asked that question come and
say: You can explain some of it, but not most
of it.
Most of what we're dealing with in the global
economy is a weak growth in nominal income.
And that's-you know, that is something where
the measurement issues are just much, much,
much smaller.
Most of this measurement stuff comes down
to the distinction between nominal and real.
Our ability to measure nominal incomes are
a lot better.
And what-the problem, I would argue, that
we're all struggling with is a nominal income
problem.
MALLABY: Another question?
Yes, right here.
Q: I'm Kenneth Bialkin with Skadden Arps.
When we hear your discussion, it's clearly
premised on a collective objective of improving
our economy, our employment, and the condition
of the American people, consumers and workers.
What I'm confused about is when we talk about
China, which you've talked about a little
bit, when China's rulers, who are not necessarily
responsible to their voters, look at what
to do with the U.S. economy in terms of their
activity-selling, buying, moving, not moving-they
don't care about American productivity.
They care about the interests that are interesting
to them.
My question to you is, on the decisions made
by the rulers of China as to how to act with
relationship to the American economy, are
they favoring, are they interested, let's
stay, in the employment rate of the Chinese
worker?
Are they interested in the welfare of the
Chinese consumer?
Or are they focused more primarily on political
or other interests having to do with their
longer-range prospects?
In other words, a difference between China
and America in this conversation that we're
having, how do you evaluate that?
MALLABY: Well, OK, maybe let's go to Jim first.
I mean, I think what strikes me about the
question is that it is true that in a non-market
economy with a lot of state direction the
objection of certain patterns of trading and
so forth may be political.
So when you see a wave of Chinese external
investment buying up German robotics companies
or American hotel chains, is this purely a
market transaction, they want to make a profit,
or is there some political agenda?
GRANT: Yeah.
Well, with all the humility of someone who
lives not in China, but rather in Brooklyn,
let me propose a couple of thoughts.
One is there appears to be a rather urgent
movement of funds out of China.
My second observation is that I propose to
you that China might be fairly regarded as
a kind of financial dystopia, in which the
state sets the rules principally for the benefit
of those already in power, namely the Communist
Party and the friends of the Communist Party.
And I think that China is-financially speaking-is
the world's biggest problem.
And I suggest to you that one day we will
wake up and hear or read that there has been
a collapse in the wealth management products
of the Chinese shadow banking and banking
systems.
These wealth management products are closed
and, indeed, blind pools.
One doesn't know what's in them.
They principally invest in credit instruments-bonds
and the like.
Three-point-six trillion (dollars') worth.
In a $10 1/2 trillion economy these things
are growing $4(00) or $500 billion a year.
The principal technique for the redemption
of wealth management products is the issuance
of new wealth management products.
And the word Ponzi was in fact applied to
this phenomenon by a leading Chinese banker
a couple of years ago.
A couple of years ago means that it has been
going on, and kept going on, and defying the
bears who see in it-as do I. I certainly am
bearish on this.
I see the world's greatest financial risk.
So, sir, you asked what the Chinese want.
I think they want to remain in power.
The rulers want to remain in power.
They are interested in the manipulation of
information to that end.
markets to that end.
And I think that what is going on within China
financially is very, very worrying.
DINSMORE: I think I would add onto that, if
you look at the history of China since 1979,
the rise in Chinese soft power globally has
been economically driven.
And for the Chinese government, the economy
is one of its most powerful tools.
No one would be talking about China if China
didn't have the extraordinary growth rate
that it has had over the last few years.
And so I believe that it is in the interest
of the Chinese party to stay in power.
And to stay in power, it is in their interest
to keep their economy growing, at least at
some rate that doesn't cause social unrest,
which is why I think that they end up kicking
the can down the road and they don't want
to agitate anything in the economy, and try
to be so cautious in that.
I think politically that creates a-starting
to get out of my realm of expertise as an
economist-but politically it creates an interesting
backdrop for the Communist Party, where as
the economy slows, there are increasing calls
for more representation from the people.
And I think that you're starting to see some
concerns among the Party members about their
own hold on power as the economy slows.
So you've seen a lot of finger pointing, a
lot of dissension within the Party.
And so, for me, I think if you're looking
at the outlook for China, there's an inextricable
link between economic stability and the ability
for them to continue under the one party system.
MALLABY: Yeah.
And last word for Lewis.
ALEXANDER: Just three quick things very quickly.
First of all, I total agree that the biggest
risk we face in the globe the Chinese financial
system, and the risk of a problem there.
That's number one.
Number two, the material improvement in the
lives of the Chinese people over the last
30 years is probably the single greatest improvement
like that we've-in human history.
So whatever else you think about what the
Chinese are doing, I think you kind of have
to acknowledge that this is the greatest economic
success story for the broadest number of people
we've ever experienced.
The third thing I would just say is, it seems
to me it's on us to manage our relationship
with China in way that's good for us.
And that I don't know.
You know, one of the problems, frankly, with
China, one of the things I worry about, is
we do not understand how they make decisions.
So it's hard-it's hard to answer your question
directly.
But ultimately, it's on us to make sure that
our economic relationship with China is one
that's productive for us.
MALLABY: OK.
So from Brexit to China, it's been a great
sprint around the world.
Thank you to all panelists and thank you for
coming out.
(Applause.)
(END)
This is an uncorrected transcript.